[Music]
we are an unusual couple
it was really so fun getting to play all
these different decades
throughout juan division we just don't
know what to expect
and then of course everything kind of
breaks down and becomes an mcu version
of the real world am i dead
no why would you think that because you
are can't believe how it just keeps
unraveling
and unfolding in ways that i am still
shocked and thrilled by
[Applause]
i think it's going to be really
satisfying for people when they realize
what is at the heart of this show this
is our home
then let's fight for it
it's warren welcome back to the cosmic
wonder where we talk about things marvel
and
everything mcu and it seems like marvel
has a bit of a trend going on here
it appears that before each episode
releases they're going to drop a little
bit of a teaser
and preview of what's to come in that
episode and i'm going to break down
what's coming in episode 6 but first
and a big thank you to atlas vpn for
sponsoring this video
i know a lot of people in some countries
don't actually get disney plus and can't
watch wanda vision
and if that is you atlas vpn is the
solution for you
even if you don't have disney plus where
you are located right now you can use
atlas vpn to access disney plus and
watch wanda vision
atlas vpn is a tool that encrypts your
data and hides your virtual location
when you connect to a vpn server your
device is given a new ip and dns address
all of the traffic is then encrypted and
routed towards the vpn server the vpn
then decrypts the information
and allows you to access the desired
location of your choice giving you
access to media and websites of that
select location
so if you don't have disney plus in your
country you can use atlas vpn to access
disney plus
in say america or somewhere in europe
places that actually do have disney plus
and atlas vpn is supported on any device
i currently use it right now to watch
friends on the european server since
it's not in america
and the great news is right now atlas
vpn is only a dollar
39 a month with their 3-year deal with a
30-day
money-back guarantee so be sure to check
it out by clicking the link in the video
description
down below so we know that episode 6 is
going to be
the infamous halloween episode where
wanda envisioned
both dress up for halloween as the comic
accurate versions of themselves and
spoiler alert for one of vision episode
5
if you haven't seen it yet we know that
evan peterson's quicksilver is going to
be a big part in this episode as well
but there's something that paul bettany
said in this video that is very very
specific as to what we're about to see
in episode six
he says in this featurette of course
everything breaks down and kind of
becomes
the mcu version of the real world and as
they show him saying this we see the
scene
where he touches agnes and awakens her
and we know it's this episode coming up
because she is dressed as
a witch kind of foreshadowing who she
actually is
agatha harkness or a very powerful witch
now it seems very clear based off of
what we've seen that things are going to
start to
unravel and as paul bettany said become
the real world
now up until now vision and wanda have
been living
in this fake reality created by wanda or
somebody else they also teased that this
is the episode that vision is going to
try and escape
this energy bubble that wand has put
around the town in episode 5
vision has realized that it's wanda
controlling everybody and it's wanda
keeping him in west view he realizes
that
he has absolutely no recollection of
what has happened before he got to
westview now of course we know that
vision was dead he died in infinity war
and wanda broke into a sword facility
gathered the parts of his body and
brought him back to life or at least
that's what we're made to believe
but we may be finding out more about
that in this episode because in episode
5
vision asked why are there no other
children in westview but as we just saw
in the teaser for episode 6 when they go
trick-or-treating there are many
other kids running around now the big
question about this
is which we'll find out tonight is that
are these kids
real did wanda create them in this new
reality or
is this perhaps the real world we know
vision is going to try and escape
will he be successful at that but also
in this preview we see a scene that
we've seen before and it's the woman
hanging up her clothes to dry
and she's crying now we've previously
learned from norm
that whatever is going on whether it's
wanda putting a hex on them and
controlling them
it's very painful so whoever this woman
is hanging up her clothes
is definitely being controlled and she's
definitely in pain to the point to where
she's crying she's probably also crying
at the fact that she's being controlled
but it's very clear that this is going
to be
noticed by wanda or vision and at this
point it's clear that vision is not okay
with what is happening so if it is
vision who finds out he's probably going
to try and do something about it and it
also does seem like wanda
is fully realizing that she is control
over this reality we see her sitting on
the couch
working her magic to change how things
are so as i expected for some time now
wanda herself might actually be under a
little bit of a spell whether that's of
her own doing or somebody else's
but it looks like she's figuring that
out and it looks like this whole
bubble reality that wanda created is
kind of crashing
and going into the real reality like
paul bettany said well it looks like we
have some
major reveals coming tonight so be sure
to join me for my watch party at
3 a.m eastern time if you have disney
plus we can hit play at the same time
and all watch together so be sure to
subscribe and turn that notification
bell on so you don't miss out on any of
the latest videos
don't forget to give the video a like
and for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you